how tough is it to build an emp
any nuclear weapon that
will generate an electromagnetic pulse
but uh there are also non-nuclear emp
weapons that would be part of this
scenario
the us air force has one called champ
it's basically a cruise missile and it
carries a non-nuclear emp generator
and uh it doesn't generate a field as
big as a nuclear weapon i mean a single
nuclear weapon is really all you'd need
to block take out the whole u.s electric
grid detonated at very high altitude but
with a couple of dozen maybe 20 of of
these cruise missiles or drones carrying
non-nuclear electromagnetic pulse
generators they would follow the power
lines and uh it would take hours instead
of
a second uh you know but they could
achieve the same thing and and black out
the power grid
countries like iran
uh and even terrorist groups are capable
of of harnessing non-nuclear emp weapons
and using them in this way
they have the sophistication to do that
so it's not hard at all as a matter of
fact
if you had the money you can actually
buy emp devices not intended to be used
as weapons but they could be could be
used as weapon there's a
device called the emp suitcase that
looks just like a suitcase it's designed
to be operated and carried by one man it
puts out a hundred thousand volts
hundred thousand volts per meter over a
short distance a hundred yards that
right there yes that's it i i i just
something like that go for i think 50
000. okay that's not a lot of money not
for a terrorist group or a nation state
but if you had
a a a terrorist or a criminal or a
disgruntled individual got one of those
things and he put in the chunk of his
car and he drove up to an extra high
voltage power substation i mean you see
these when you drive down the highway
all the time you know we've arrived at a
place technologically where a single
individual could topple the pillars
technological pillars of civilization
for an entire metropolitan area like
miami or new york or boston just by
himself just with that and if you had it
just with that yeah and if you had a
team of guys running around the country
you could black out the whole national
electric grid just just with these
devices how come it's not happened yet
well
uh it has happened in chechnya and other
places uh it hasn't happened in this
country yeah well i'll give them time
you know
you know i don't know why it hasn't
happened yet we've been lucky you know
uh uh the great german statesman otto
von bismarck once said you know god
looks after uh uh fools drunkards little
children in the united states of america
maybe that's why it hasn't happened but
has anyone been caught attempting to do
something of this capacity we've uh we
haven't caught somebody with the rf
briefcase yet but we have caught uh you
know
actually i haven't called the person but
there was a uh
a drone in pennsylvania uh somebody flew
a drone now uh you know
you know that tried to make a different
kind of an attack against the power line
i'm not sure i
want to get into all the technical
details there was an incident uh
a few not too long ago uh that happened
in uh canada uh where a disgruntled
individual
uh used it wasn't a radio frequency
weapon but it was
a different technology even simpler
that enabled him to black out
temporarily the hydroquebec
grid in canada put millions of people
into the dark
you know they did correct it after a day
but one guy did that and uh so there
have been attacks on electric grids here
in north america
there were attacks in the electric grid
in mexico by the uh back in 2013 yeah
the knights templars they're a drug
cartel
they used explosives and small arms to
attack uh to black out the electric grid
in the province of mexico they put about
a half million people into the dark so
that they could go into the towns and
villages and publicly execute people who
were opposed to the drugs trade the the
village elders and leaders who were
opposed to the drug trade uh you know so
if neanderthals like the knights
templars have figured out that the
electric grid is a keystone societal
vulnerability just think with al qaeda
or isis or
north korea and these much more
sophisticated actors could do we're very
lucky i mean i was kind of surprised
when isis was on the ropes that they
didn't just pay the knights templars to
come across the border i mean you know
and say hey go do go to the united
states which you guys did in mexico
we've been i i think the reason we had
it has hasn't happened yet is because
we've been lucky these guys are from
michoacan they're michoacan yeah
that was the province that i know a lot
of people from each other
we've got to keep an eye on them yeah
good friends by the way going back to
this so you know what i would do if i
was that if i was a us government
i would buy that company
who sells those suitcases
everybody that buys it they would be on
alert
that's exactly what i would do yeah
there's no way in the world i'm going to
let that stay
without i'd overpay to find out who the
hell is doing this i'd go into
partnership and figure out and have a
cia guy we'll have working for that
company point out so i don't get sued
okay
but that has legitimate peaceful
purposes they don't intend it to be used
as a weapon oh i'm not worried about
there's there's guns that are intended
to peaceful purposes in the wrong guy's
hand that's the one thing exactly it's
it's potentially a weapon of mass how do
you use that for peaceful purposes and
you don't even need a license to buy it
unlike a gun you need a license to buy a
gun but you can buy that without a
license how is that used for peaceful
purposes well yeah you know if you're
designing an airport for example okay
okay and you want to know how far away
do i have to put the runway so that the
radars don't fry the electronics and
airplanes when you're landing
you can use a device like that to
simulate the pulse that's coming off the
radar to see how far things have to be
spaced or if you're laying out if you've
got a factory and it's got a lot of
heavy electronic equipment drill presses
metal bending equipment stuff that uses
a lot of electricity they put out
powerful electromagnetic transients and
this kind of equipment is spaced too
closely together they can fry each other
and commit fatricide okay so you need to
know how far apart how thick does the
shielding have to be and that's what
it's intended to be used for you know to
to help you
you know you don't want to have to move
the equipment in and learn by by
experience you know how far apart should
i have put the drill presses and things
like that you know that that's what it's
intended for so it has it does have a
legitimate uh legitimate purpose but
perhaps uh
you know the uh but perhaps it should be
licensed then we should have better
control [ __ ] i mean yeah and perhaps no
just anybody shouldn't be able to
purchase we're but we're not the only
ones i mean this is a us company there's
a german company that sells sells they
saying i'm sure terrorists already have
them and terrorists have used them in
chechnya you asked why hasn't happened
here the chechen terrorists figured out
how to use them against the russians
russians in in chechnya they used to
to kill the electronics so they can go
in and kill everybody in a in a military
base let me ask you a question earlier
you were talking about nuclear shelter
so i pulled up a couple numbers here
israel has nuclear shelters i think
sweden has like 63 000 or something
nuclear shelters a lot of different
countries have nuclear
shelters so
if we whether that is something we have
or not it's definitely not talked about
openly amongst people do we have nuclear
shelters in
cities and communities where if
something were to happen here's what we
have
uh fiba would probably say we do okay
but
there's an enormous difference between
what we've
what
you know what fema did you know back
when we had a
a significant civil defense program
you've probably seen those civil defense
signs you know the the radioactive
symbol
uh sometimes they'll be in the basement
of a library or something like that
that's what our shelter is you know
those aren't the kinds of shelters
they've got in russia okay these are uh
you know these are not
serious shelters that are designed
to survive uh you know a nuclear war
they are they will provide you it's
better than nothing i mean it's better
to be in the shelter of a library okay
if a nuclear blast happens uh or if
there's radioactive fallout coming down
so you don't get directly exposed to it
but we don't have anything like what the
russians have got
in the intelligence community they're
called deep underground shelters or
dougs all right i'm talking about
you know some of the more famous ones
are chekhov and sharapova kazavinsky
mountain yamatow mountain these are
shelters that are
hundreds of meters deep on solid granite
they're impervious to nuclear attack is
that is that a form of a shelter right
there
is that a nuclear shelter well that's a
uh i think that's a missile silo
do you know what these shelters look
like like this this look this is a
moscow uh
uh nuclear shelter right here is this
kind of what it looks like i it's hard
for me to see
over there i don't have my i'd just be
curious i'd be curious to know what
these nuclear shelters look like
that's the one i was looking at right
there i think that's a uh
russia ready for doomsday it's deeply
buried
uh that's a i i think that's a missile
silo i mean that looks like the head
works for a missile silo but that could
be that could be the head works to one
of their wh one of their shelters but
that that looks like the uh uh a missile
silo to me so fema would say we have
nuclear shelters uh they probably would
because they're you know uh they're
optimists and they uh they always put
the best possible possible spin on thing
but we but we don't uh even for our
political military leadership uh
the most famous
uh
shelter in the america is cheyenne
mountain norad the nora
alternate headquarters okay
this was built in the
designed in the 40 late 40s and early
50s and it was designed to survive an
atomic attack where's that uh it's in
cheyenne mountain uh was that wyoming
where is it yeah
near peterson air force base
no no the state as well as i do uh i
think it's in colorado
but i'm not slowly sure that this earth
is safe but it's very close to peterson
air force base which is norad
headquarters and space command
headquarters and and cheyenne mountain
is located near there it used to be it's
now the alternate uh head headquarters
and uh yeah uh and uh it's inside of a
mountain and the buildings are are on
springs to survive a shock wave and
that's the best hardest facility we have
that facility will not survive an attack
from a hydrogen bomb
it'll survive an atomic bomb but it's
not hard enough for an atomic bomb a
hydrogen bomb their shelters will
survive attacks
probably even by our most powerful
weapon which is the was the b83 and uh
uh some of these shelters are
we call them shelters but yamantan
mountain for example and we
we still don't know the purpose maybe
it's for these
oligarchs who are fleeing to the ural
mountains but uh the yamanta mountain
facility is is is is like an underground
city that can survive a uh a a nuclear
attack is this is this a nuclear shelter
this is an article guardian did saying
how the u.s has prepared for nuclear
armageddon in this picture they're
talking about this was
something they started working on since
the truman days oh i was preferred i
don't know that looks like uh
i know that some millionaires have
purchased old atlas silos and uh that
looks like one of those uh you know uh
you know and this atlas was hardened to
survive and attack so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]
you